mr sharma thank you for joining us can
you reassure viewers
that the lights are going to stay on
this winter well trevor thank you for
having me on your your program uh well
obviously people reading what's in the
in the press will be concerned about the
supply of of energy
the impact on on prices as you will know
the the business secretary has been
having detailed discussions with the
sector this weekend he'll be continuing
those today and it's going to be a round
table tomorrow but i think the the clear
message that is coming out of this is
that there is no immediate concern in
terms of supply we don't see any risks
uh going into the winter and when it
comes to prices
we of course have an energy price cap
there are also mechanisms such as the
warm home discount which are available
to support people as well so people
should be confident uh that uh the
supplies will be there and that we will
be protecting them uh in terms of price
rises but of course we're not complacent
about this and that's precisely why the
business actually is having these very
detailed discussions with the sector i i
know you've got to say all of that but
this is sort of um i know what people
are going to be saying as they're
watching oh god there's a don't panic
message from dad's army now is the
moment to panic
we're looking at 70 plus rises in gas
prices um
just at a practical level isn't it a
moment where you could for example
reconsider the cut the 20 20 pounds a
week cut in universal credit to reassure
particularly
uh poor families that they are not going
to have to freeze in their homes this
this winter well i mean let's talk about
firstly the price issue because that's a
very important one there is a reason we
introduced the energy price cap it is to
protect millions of people as i said
when it comes to driving when it comes
to flyers out of business well when it
comes
to this business
let me address that issue but when it
comes to supporting those who are on
lower incomes we of course have uh the
warm hinge discount uh winter fuel
payments and other mechanisms in place
so we are there to support people when
it comes to these costs um and actually
you know talking about the supply
significant element of the the gas
supply in the uk is domestic
where we have imports they'll be coming
from secure places like norway
and people should feel confident that
this is something that the government of
course is not being complacent about but
they should feel confident that the
supply will be there
but the truth is that uh you don't know
that
you don't know that uh
and you can
issue as many rear messages reassurance
as you like but
there might be at least a case for
saying let's
help those families let's at least hold
open the possibility that if prices do
go up you can help those families well
we are helping those families as i said
there is the warm homes discount uh
there are other payments that are made
to those on lower incomes and of course
we've got the price cap so that support
is is absolutely there and i want to
reassure people that is not going away
and as i said when it comes to supply uh
you know uh at this point in time we
feel confident that there is not a risk
and of course of course
this is not about complacency trevor you
you made the point about uh you know
dad's army it certainly isn't that i
mean i'm a dad but uh
just to be clear there's nothing to do
with dad something this is a really uh
laser-like focus that the business
secretary has on this issue and that's
why uh he is convening uh all these uh
these groups and making sure that
actually we do uh uh have a solution
longer term to this and and part of that
solution by the way since we're going to
talk about cop part of that solution
part of that solution is rolling out
more renewables you know in the last 10
years we've quadrupled the amount of
renewables we have in the country we've
got the biggest offshore wind sector in
the world trevor we want to quadruple
that as well by 2030. but that's how you
take care of energy security and energy
supply is building out domestically when
it comes to renewables but actually
that's it that's exactly part of the
point the the your shadow or the shadow
uh energy secretary
ed miliband's made the point that you've
been talking about renewables and all
the rest of it for the last 10 years
but you can't be absolutely sure because
you haven't got on with it that we will
have uninterrupted supply because there
just isn't enough that's been generated
by renewables you haven't opened new
nuclear capacity as you thought as you
said you would
well i think i have to say it's entirely
wrong to say that we haven't built out
renewables we've quadrupled the amount
of renewables uh over the last 10 years
and i said we now have the biggest
offshore wind sector in the world and to
make this point you know people talk a
lot about coal for instance back in 2012
travel 40 percent of our electricity was
coming from coal it's now less than two
percent and by the end of 2024 there
will be no more coal in our electricity
mix and the reason is precisely because
we have built a big renewable sector
will you um
take the opportunity now then to rule
out uh a new coal mine uh in cumbria
which is what is uh on the card and
which the government has sort of kicked
down the road until
cop after cop 26. why don't you just
tell us no more no more new coal
capacity yeah
well so i think in terms of this coal
mine and it's been discussed many times
there is no coal mine at this stage
there's a public inquiry which which is
ongoing right now so i mean i don't want
to comment and say what you don't want
capacity there is a reason that uh in
our sort of democratic process is that
we have public inquiries everybody gets
a chance to have their say
and that inquiry is still running so
let's see what comes out of that what
does the the inspectors say to that um
but i go back to this point about coal
which is that we act actually are seen
around the world as a poster child when
it comes to a clean energy transition
and we have built the biggest offshore
wind sector in the world there's no
doubt about it i mean you know coal will
be history in 2024 in our electricity
mix but with with respect the very fact
that you cannot say directly to me you
know what we do not whatever the process
is we would rather not have a new
coal mining uh facility in cumbria on
stream in the next few years the fact
you cannot say that to me will send a
message around the world that actually
though you talk a good game
you don't really do the business trevor
let's see what comes out of the public
inquiry but you know my message i mean
you sort of said that i'm responsible
for this this climate conference my
message is going around the world and
ensuring that we have all countries
committing to phasing out coal in their
energy mix as the uk has done and
actually we are seen as leading in the
world in this issue all right well
you're off to new york this afternoon to
talk to people from around the world
with the prime minister to try i guess
to set up
the deal um
your heart must have sunk this week when
the prime minister and mr biden and mr
morrison announced a new deal and the
french went uh
a bit crazy about it and the chinese
didn't denounce it as irresponsible it's
not the best diplomatic environment is
it to get a deal well look i mean this
is a trilateral deal between three very
close partners this is about the in the
pacific uh and we've been very clear
this isn't about provoking anyone we
want to have good relations with all
countries we want to work with mutual
trust with all countries but in terms of
what in terms of my role whatever you
wanted
in terms of my role trevor what i can
tell you is that i personally have
spoken to world leaders uh ministers and
over a hundred governments and there is
a very unified view on this they do see
climate change as an issue which is a
great leveler climate change does not
respect borders and countries
individually see what is going on in
their own country i mean you've seen
literally in the last few weeks
the horrific flooding that's been in
china in central europe uh loss of life
and livelihoods you've seen wildfires
raging in in north america record
temperatures in in europe this is all
down to climate change and that is why
countries recognize that we need to act
collectively and together and why i am
told by every country that i speak to is
they do want cop 26 to be a success okay
every country um simple answer here
you've got 100 leaders who said they're
coming
has president xi jinping of china said
he's coming
uh no not yet uh but as you know i was
in in china recently i had uh
constructed but very frank discussions
uh with china and of course they've made
various commitments on on cutting
emissions on on phasing down the use of
coal and i was very clear i said to them
that we want to see the detailed policy
around this and they along with every
other major economy the g20 have
committed before cop 26 driver to come
forward with
ambitious plans to cut emissions um and
i have to say to you that in every
conversation i had with the chinese they
were very clear they were very clear
that they want to see cop 26 as a
success so the ball is very much in
their court well they're they're all
kind of definitions of success aren't
there china
is mining four billion
uh four million tons of coal a year
it is the biggest emitter in the world
is xi jinping going to turn up and sign
a deal because without china it's all
pretty meaningless isn't it well there's
no doubt that china is going to be part
of the key to all of this absolutely
they're the biggest emitter in the world
and what president xi jinping has said
is that they're going to strictly
restrict the use of coal in this next
five-year period from 2026 they're going
to phase down
but of course we want to see the detail
of that that is what is really important
here as well
and that's what we're pressing them and
i repeat the point they've said to me
they want cop 26 to be a success well
you know the ball is in their court we
want them to come forward and make it a
success together with the rest of the
world talking about detail um
your colleagues in cabinet have
just signed a trade deal with the
australians
in which
they omitted
any specific
numbers in relation to the australians
uh a coal production and emissions uh
which had previously been in the what
the australians signed in the paris
accord now
you say the detailed matters actually
what your government's just done is
taken out the details uh that would have
tied one of the biggest coal producers
in the world to proper targets well
trevor you're right detail actually
matters and this deal has not yet been
signed it's an outline form and the
legal text is being worked on but i just
want to clarify this point that the uk
has some of the strongest environmental
uh uh
uh uh measures in the world we are not
compromising that in our trade deals and
when it comes to australia but let me
address that point because when it comes
to australia there is absolutely going
to be a substantive uh clause in that
deal which makes reference to the
commitment of both countries to the
paris agreement and the goals of the
paris agreement so it is going to be
there in black and white are going to be
tied to numbers they are going to be
tied to the commitments that are made in
the paris agreement and the parents
agreement is very clear in terms of uh
where we want to see the limiting in
temperature rises uh in in the world uh
and just to be clear that uh you know
parliament uh very select companies are
going to have an opportunity to
scrutinize this deal they're already
looking at the outline when the detailed
text is agreed they will have a chance
to scrutinize this so
but i want to be very very very clear on
this point is that we are not
compromising in terms of the
environmental measures that we have in
our country that hard won uh as a
conservative government i'm really proud
that this is what we are doing and
supporting and of course if you look in
in the in the trade deals that we want
to negotiate we want to talk about how
do we also expand
uh
the the the import and export of green
goods for instance the resources
minister of australia said
the reports of cold impending death are
greatly exaggerated and its future is
assured well beyond 2030. that doesn't
sound like a government that is
preparing to wind down its production of
uh
of of
coal well let me make a wider point
about coal which is that if you look at
the the cost of renewables around the
world it is cheaper to install new
renewables in the vast majority of the
world than it is to have coal power
plants if you look at investments in
coal the private sector is increasingly
reluctant to invest in coal because they
can see these are going to become
stranded assets and actually we talked
about china i mean if you look at some
of the statements coming out of some of
the biggest banks in china which do
financing of international coal they've
said that they're going to be setting
out plans to phase down uh that
financing of core projects uh uh around
the world uh and i think so we are
seeing a move where coal will become
consigned to history but we do want
every country to step up on this point
all right um
you've got
a couple of days in new york to solve
the problem
you must admit that what has happened
this week
must have made the
environment the climate for those
negotiations
more difficult the french are furious
with us the americans who knows where
they are uh there is a standoff all
around and the chinese are really being
aggressive on the uh on the american and
british foreign policy your life must be
made being made much more difficult than
it needs to be well trevor the last 18
months uh you know and we've had all
sorts of uh you know
bilateral matters multilateral matters
that have been going on over the past 18
months i have been getting access
talking to governments as i said i've
spent over 100 governments personally
and that is because uh people know that
my focus is on climate uh and they all
understand the reason we need to solve
this together as i said you know i'm
told by every country that i meet they
want uh cop 26 to be a success and we
need to hold them to it and what will
success look look like for you
well it's numbers that will come out of
cop 26 that will be successful well what
we want to do is to ensure that we are
limiting uh a global warming uh in the
paris agreement uh world leaders set out
in 2015 that uh you know we would seek
to limit the rising global temperatures
to well below two degrees uh aiming for
1.5 degrees and we want to get to a
point where we can say that we have kept
1.5 alive i want to make this really a
really important point because we talk
as politicians about
these numbers and lots of people
watching this will say well yeah 1.5
degrees doesn't sound like a lot but
actually currently the world is one
point degree two degrees warmer than
before pre-industrial levels and you are
seeing the impact of that around the
world in our own country you're seeing
an increase in flooding increase in in
rain and that's just going to get worse
rising sea levels that's just going to
get worse and that's why we need to
collectively work and particularly the
biggest emitters to g20 need to come
forward and set out ambitious plans to
cut the mission